[ Music ]
>> The Sonoran Desert to a number of venomous
creatures that can cause problems for people;
particularly those living in rural areas.
In Arizona, there are 30 species of scorpion,
and about 8,000 scorpion stings each year.
While these stings are painful, most
can be managed with basic first aid.
But the sting of one species,
the Arizona Bark Scorpion,
can be deadly; especially small children.
>> In Arizona, children who are stung
by scorpions will sometimes develop a nerve
poisoning syndrome that is really frightening.
They have a set of symptoms that comes from all
of the different nerves of the body being kind
of stuck in the on position simultaneously.
And all of their muscles lose control.
So, that there may be one twitching,
and one jerking, and a little inhalation
and a little exhalation all at the same time.
When you put it all together,
they don't breathe very well.
Dr. Leslie Bowyer is an expert
on desert creatures.
Ten years ago, when she learned
that an antivenom being used
in Arizona would no longer be available,
she began seeking an alternative.
>> Children who don't get
antivenom need intensive care
for sometimes as long as two days.
During that time, they get extremely high doses
of sedative drugs to make them hold still.
Because the thrashing and jerking that
they're doing can be dangerous just by itself.
Because this condition is one that
comes from interacting with the desert,
it's much more likely that people who live
far from the center of town will be stung.
Which means this is a small-town disease.
It's a rare, potentially
life-threatening condition in towns
that don't have intensive care units.
>> Dr. Boyer began a study of a
promising anti-venom produced in Mexico
that had never been tested to US standards.
One of the study subjects was a little boy
from Globe, Arizona, Morgan Bray [phonetic].
>> Morgan, he was playing after lunch at school,
and they have these big cement tunnel
things that they were playing in.
They were digging in the san,
and he was bit on the finger.
And I got a call probably
half an hour after he got bit.
Went and got him, he was crying that it hurt.
Next thing I know he comes to me, and he says,
"Mom, my legs aren't working; I can't walk."
So, I took him to the hospital,
and while we're driving,
Morgan says, "Mommy, I don't want to die."
>> When Morgan was a baby, his two-year-old
brother, Dally, suffered a scorpion sting.
He was rushed to the hospital and given
the antivenom that was then available.
But he had an allergic reaction to one
of the components, and did not survive.
At the time, Morgan was stung, Dr. Boyer's
study of the antivenom from Mexico had advanced
to clinical trials that were
being conducted in Tucson.
>> So I get to the ER; I carry him
in there and I get him signed in.
And the guy says, "Okay, sit down
we'll be with you just shortly."
And I said, "No sir, I don't think so.
I've already lost one son to this,
I'm not going to do -- do it again."
Dr. Gonzales got on the phone immediately to
Dr. Boyer and we were on air vac within an hour.
Morgan had a full -- what
they call "bag a worms".
His tongue was going crazy; his eyes.
He was just going nuts.
He freaked me out.
And they gave him the antivenom.
They filmed him for research.
And I think I remember asking,
"Is that all he's getting?"
And he was already coming out of
it, and we were home by 10:30,
and he played baseball the next day.
Honestly, I thought I was going
to have to bury another baby.
>> This study has had remarkable
results for the children
and families who have participated in it.
And it has had a wide reach
for the people of Arizona.
Especially those in rural communities.
Because of it, the lifesaving
antivenom is available
in hospital emergency departments
throughout the state.
>> We've learned that in Arizona, it is possible
to do amazing things if you ask for help.
We pulled together a team
involving 24 hospitals.
Several hundred doctors.
Several hundred nurses.
Several hundred pharmacists.
And administrators working
together as volunteers
to make an absolutely unprecedented
study network that allows us to make sure
that no matter where you live in the Sonoran
Desert, antivenom is near your home [music].
>> This study has also paved the way for future
efforts to find safe, effective treatment
for the hazards of living in the desert.
Because of the antivenom study, a team
of trained professionals is in place,
and prepared to do a type of research
that is unique to this region.